bonjour à vous françois durpaire merci
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin
alors que se passe-t-il exactement 1
portland mais aussi dans plusieurs
villes américaines depuis près de deux
mois depuis la mort en fait un de
l'afro-américain georgia floyd
oui bonjour samantha il se passe que
effectivement depuis deux mois le
blacklight matin est un mouvement vous
savez qui est un mouvement qui existe
depuis 2013 et qui est qui et structuré
qui est organisée de telle sorte qu'il
est en capacité de mobiliser dans
l'ensemble des villes américaines des
grandes villes américaines mais aussi
des villes moyennes américaines ce qui
fait que vous avez des manifestations
mais aussi des forums à ciel ouvert des
discussions
une grande partie de cette génération
millénium qui est mobilisé deux jeunes
tailleurs de toutes les origines qui se
mobilisent contre le racisme et qui
discutent de la société d'aujourd'hui et
vous avez face à cette mobilisation
une réaction fédérale qui est de l'avis
de beaucoup inappropriée une
militarisation de la réponse à la fois
sur le plan rhétorique de la part du
président des états unis mais aussi dans
l'intervention d'agents du département
de la sécurité intérieure la fameuse dhs
qui ne correspond pas en fait à la
réalité du terrain c'est à dire que la
réponse ces deux militariser la police
et de considérer qu'en fait il ya une
guerre dans les rues américaines
vous vous souvenez du propos de
d'intrants disant qu'il s'agissait ces
manifestations de groupes paramilitaires
terroristes un simple reportage neutre
de vos équipes montrent qu'il s'agit en
fait de jeunes et même s'il ya parfois
des infiltrations de groupes plus
peut-être plus violents la réponse
fédérale et est en tout cas inapproprié
alors quand vous dites que la réponse
fédérale et est inappropriée elle est
contestée par plusieurs maires pour que
l'on comprenne bien le contexte
américain
ça représente quoi l'intervention de la
police fédérale pour les américains
alors dans l'esprit des américains c'est
intéressant ce que vous dites parce
qu'il ya eu une enquête une étude de
2018 alors qu'évidemment en tailleur aux
manifestations mais qui demandait aux
américains si par rapport à ce type de
manifestation il souhaitait
l'intervention de troupes fédérales et
les américains répondez non c'est en
fait à la fois inefficace pour eux mais
ca va aussi avoir une image négatif
négatif de la police mais aussi de
l'armée
quand on brouille en fait la séparation
entre police police locale et armés aux
états unis et bien c'est ni positif pour
la police ni positif pour l'armée les
américains considèrent est bien quand on
ne doit pas traiter ces manifestations
comme on traite bien une guérilla
urbaine
or même dans le champ lexical des deux
d'entre eux ils utilisent ce thème de la
guérilla ce thème du terrorisme qui pour
beaucoup d'américains qui ne sont pas
seulement les américains démocrates
eh bien ce sont des propos qui sont
excessifs et l'intervention de ses
troupes fédérales sont aix et vous
rappelez du ministre de la guerre de la
défense marque espère qu'ils disaient il
est hors de question de faire intervenir
l'armée
or ce que fut donald trump aujourd'hui
est bien c'est de faire intervenir des
troupes qui sont à mi chemin entre
l'armée et la police notamment cette
fameuse dhs alors on voit que ce
mouvement ces émeutes contre le racisme
les brutalités policières aux états unis
se poursuit
on est à quelques encablures de la
présidentielle ça veut dire que ce sont
des thématiques qui vont peser sur la
campagne présidentielle
oui tout à fait de samantha ça pèse déjà
sur la campagne et on peut dire qu'on a
un peu de campagne parallèle d'un côté
les démocrates et joe biden qui parle
beaucoup à la fois d'économies avec son
fameux buy american achetez américain
mais qui parle aussi du coc vite 19 de
la nécessité de se sortir de la pandémie
je vous rappelle qu'on est en contexte
très délicat aux états unis avec une
explosion de cas dans certains états un
peu partie particulièrement parler du
texas ou de la floride
et puis de l'autre donald trump qui
continue à parler de la loi et l'ordre
continuent à avoir un discours très
autoritaire avec finalement un discours
de mobilisation pour sa base électorale
mais qui peut se retourner contre lui
parce qu'elles mobilisent également
eh bien les démocrates la la base d'un
jeunesse démocrate qui n'auraient pas
forcément voté pour joe biden ils ont
plutôt voté pour bernie sanders dans
lors de l'élection primaire mais qui par
réaction est bien vont se retourner
contre le président américain si
possible en le début novembre prochain
alors c'est vrai que dans le camp de
donald trump et donald trump lui même il
pointe un peu du doigt aussi les faits
les maires démocrates qui sont à la tête
de ces villes où se déroulent ces
émeutes
alors que la campagne présidentielle
elle suit son cours oui tout à fait le
maire de porte l'un de vous parler de
portables tout à l'heure tu aides
oui leyne a reçu vous le savez il ya
quelques jours des gaz lacrymogènes
c'est ces mères sont parfois au sein de
ces manifestations aux côtés des
communautés locales
donald trump leurs proches et bien leur
politique publique depuis des années on
se renvoie un peu la responsabilité de
la situation
mais ce qui est intéressant dans votre
question c'est de montrer que ce
mouvement blacklight matin pendant très
longtemps c'est un mouvement de jeunes
un mouvement d'activistes un moment du
militant aujourd'hui vous êtes dans une
phase particulière où ce mouvement
eh bien il a de forts relais
institutionnels de forts relais
évidemment dans le parti démocrate des
mères
des sénateurs des représentants est
évidemment le candidat démocrate
et ça ça fait la force de blacklight
matos et pour la première fois depuis
2000 13 blacks là ce matin
et bien finalement à eux les résultats
de sa politique c'est à dire une assise
aujourd'hui institutionnels notamment au
congrès des états unis
non justement là plusieurs marques dont
celui de portland qui demande au congrès
d'intervenir afin que c'est ces agents
fédéraux soient retirés de leur ville
que peut faire donald trump pour apaiser
la situation rapidement s'il vous plaît
à françois du retard alors rapidement
samantha pour l'instant ça n'en prend
pas du tout le chemin donald trump
continue dans sa rhétorique guerrière ce
qu'on peut simplement dire c'est que il
ya aussi d'un mot des enquêtes qui sont
menées le procureur du district de
l'orégon notamment mène une enquête
contre l'intervention fédérale donc peut
attendre peut-être du côté du président
mais des choses à attendre peut-être du
côté de la justice américaine qui
enquête sur ces interventions fédéral
merci à vous françois durpaire pour
avoir répondu en direct à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes historien
spécialiste des états unis siens